- [Kelly] So well, let's talk
about "Love Is Blind" though.
- Let's do it.
- Yes.
- So how does this show work?
- Well like you said, it's
like the dating version
of "The Voice", so that's
all people can go off of,
is they, we have 15 single
guys and 15 single girls
in these dating pods, and
they talk to each other,
for days, weeks, with no
cell phone, no television,
no computers, no family
and friends in their ear,
and they just get to know each other.
- [Kelly] First of all, this
just sounds like vacation.
(laughs)
- You know what, all they
have is communication,
like the old school way of
getting to know somebody,
like talking, and asking
questions about 'em.
It's not about the superficial stuff,
what you look like, or what do you,
it's just really about who are
you, lemme get to know you.
- And it's what you look
like, not a filter (laughs).
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Not the picture you chose
to be your profile picture.
These are all people who--
- And you showed up
and they were like what?
(laughing)
- To some of them I'm like,
"Did he describe himself
to you?" 'cause we knew
what both sexes looked like
and she's like, "Yeah, he said
he looked like so-and-so."
and I was like, "Hm."
(audience laughs)
(claps)
No but honestly, people fell so in love,
so quick, that when
they did see each other
they were like, it's even
better than I thought
and there were a couple that were like,
okay, we got--
okay, okay, we'll just try this.
And then they'd hug and they were like
okay, okay, okay.
- I'm mean pretty much every
scenario you could imagine
playing itself out on the show,
it played itself out on
the show, it was wild.
it was wild.
- Cause was ya'll worried that
people wouldn't, 'cause
don't people end up
getting engaged, right,
that's the whole thing, right?
- So you have to purpose
to someone sight unseen
and accept their proposal
without every having seen them
and only after you accept do
you finally see the person
you've been talking to for
hours and hours and hours.
- But we didn't ask
anybody, nobody was forced
to purpose, so we actually, after week one
we were like if nobody purposes--
- There's the show.
(laughs)
- Then Netflix goes, then we have to
figure out what the show is,
'cause then the social
experiment would be nobody
found love without seeing
each other physically.
Well we got plenty of proposals and again,
everything you could imagine
going down, did go down.
Even, well.
- It's a whole lot.
You need to see it.
- And you got ride of, like,
any of the uncomfortable
kind of vibe 'cause when I'm
going to be meeting people
it's always like, "Oh my God."
Like and you're just,
you get to be yourself
behind that, that's why
it's like "The Voice."
- And you get away from other
people in your ear like,
"What do you see in her?
"Why are you talking to her?"
- Or going home
and googling somebody
- You're friends
or your family.
- That's annoying when people, I'm like,
"Did I ask you?"
(laughs)
- It's all about the
connection between you
and the person on the
other side of that wall
and the connections they formed were like,
just crazy strong and in like two days,
grown mean weeping.
- Tears.
Just broken. It was crazy.
- They're like, "She's the
one." and he's like, "Really?
"This show's going to be great."
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Exactly.